il arrive merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir accepté notre invitation chloé
verlhac avec ce livre si tu meurs je te
tue aux éditions plon qui honore la
mémoire de votre mari thynnus et parle
de votre reconstruction et qui est une
ode à la vie retrouvez nous retrouver
nos émissions également sur rt france
point tva bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
et
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique d arte france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec georges
kuzmanovic fondateur de république
souveraine et face à roux patrick
mennucci ancien député ps et conseiller
municipal de marseille
invité sur ce plateau également loïk le
floch prigent ancien directeur de
cabinet du ministre de l'industrie
pierre dreyfus ancien grands dirigeants
d'entreprises publiques et auteur de il
ne faut pas se tromper aux éditions
élite l1 merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france et c'était la
une cette semaine regarder les patrons
du monde entier reçu à versailles
cette semaine à l'occasion du sommet
choose france emmanuel macron a défendu
son bilan économique
les bonnes nouvelles sont là s'est
félicité le président de la république
alors que dans la rue les français
restent mobilisés contre la réforme des
retraites un projet présenté en conseil
des ministres vendredi et un avis très
critique rendu par le conseil d'état qui
juge certaines dispositions contraires à
la constitution et le recours aux
ordonnances beaucoup trop important un
coup de force dénoncé par l'opposition
essayez donc la dictature a dit emmanuel
macron réponse du leader de la france
soumise jean luc mélenchon
et aujourd'hui s'est installé dans notre
société et de manière séditieuse par des
discours politique extraordinairement
coupable l'idée que nous ne serions plus
dans une démocratie qui a une forme de
dictature qui s'est installée mais aller
en dictature une dictature c'est un
régime où une personne ou un clan
décident des lois une dictature c'est un
régime on ne change pas les dirigeants
jamais si la france c'est ça essayez la
dictature et vous verrez la dictature
elle justifie la haine la dictature elle
justifie la violence pour en sortir mais
il y as en démocratie un principe
fondamental le respect de l'autre
l'interdiction de la violence la haine à
combattre je parle d'un régime qui est
devenu autoritaire autoritaire c'est pas
un compliment démocratie il ya une
différence entre un régime autoritaire
et un régime totalitaire
les régimes totalitaires c'est la
dictature les régimes autoritaires
s'arrange pour que la violence règles ce
que la conviction des chefs n'arrive pas
à régler
et voilà ce qu'il est en train de faire
mais georges kiejman au beach est ce que
cette guerre des mots a du sens selon
vous telle qu'elle est présentée la
absolument pas d'abord quand on évoque
le millet dictature on a un président de
république monsieur macro qui a les
chevilles qui gonflent
on pense pas à lui il a été élu
justement le problème c'est que nous
sommes en démocratie représentative
nous avons une somme censée avoir une
souveraineté populaire
c'est à dire que le peuple s'exprime or
il s'avère que depuis une vingtaine
d'années il ya de plus en plus difficile
et le peuple n'est pas écouté et c'est
pour ça que lors des manifestations des
généraux les jaunes avaient comme une
des revendications principales communes
à tout le monde
le rich qui est aussi parfois simples
soient-elles montrer que le peuple
voulait reprendre en main son destin ce
qui nous vient de la révolution
française et l'un à qui la république
or on a un système politique qui petit à
petit depuis allé depuis 1983 et de
manière très accéléré
avec monsieur macron transfère toute une
partie du pouvoir de la souveraineté
nationale à une souveraineté européenne
ad non pas des industriels à de la
finance à la finance mondialisée et on a
de moins en moins le choix et le moins
en moins de possibles possibilité de
choisir et on a en face un pouvoir qui
est transnational financier qui ne
rendent compte à personne qui maintenant
grâce au traité de libre échange comme
le c'est à peu imposée aux états si les
dispositions nationales voté par les
députés du choix zee par le peuple ne
conviennent pas où vont à l'encontre de
la liberté du commerce
ils peuvent s'imposer et donc on est de
plus en plus dans une situation qui
n'est pas une dictature classique avec
un but chacune moustache une casquette
et des grands drapeaux et des armées qui
m'a brûlée lire sur les pancartes on a
des gens qui sont déconnectés des élites
déconnectées de leur nation pas qu'en
france dans toutes les grandes nations
du monde et qui suivent leur intérêt le
plus souvent contre contre leur peuple
c'est pour ça que ce qui s'est passé en
grande bretagne est très intéressant et
l'analyse qui a été faite entre les gens
qui sont de quelque part et les gens qui
sont nulle part est très très forte
c'est le jusqu'au boutisme sur cette
réforme des retraites qui fait dire à
jean luc mélenchon
qu'il ya un certain autoritarisme de la
part du gouvernement je suis pas sûr que
jean luc mélenchon le mieux placé pour
juger les dictatures ici ou là parce que
lui-même soutien non pas des régimes
autoritaires mais des dictatures comme
notamment au venezuela en ignorant la
répression qui est très violent
je ne dis pas que il n'y a pas de raison
extérieure à ce qui se passe au mieux la
nouvelle gamme c'est quelqu'un qui
soutient un régime très dictatorial là
et puis dans un certain nombre d'autres
endroits ne crois pas qu'ils font le
mieux placé non mais je les manuels
macro ils essayent là il est en train de
patauger
ils viennent de prendre un avis du
conseil d'état
jamais je crois qu'on ne vous entend pas
patrick mennucci on va régler ça dans
quelques instants du vol de micros qui
va être très vite résolu alors j'ai
beaucoup sélection avoue loïk le floch
prigent est ce que ça vous a choqué le
fait que le président recadre en tout
cas c'est ce terme de dictature qui est
entrepris dans les rues de mourir en
tant qu'industriel je dirais que le
jugement que je porte c'est plutôt le
fait que ce sont des amateurs et que les
amateurs font beaucoup de bêtises donc
je tendance à considérer que tout ça est
de l'amateurisme plus que deux d'autres
choses voilà c'est ça le jugement que je
porte et je trouve les propos de l'un et
de l'autre exagéré et est plutôt idiot
mais un jusqu'auboutisme effectivement
que l'on voit sur cette réforme des
retraites ainsi le maintien en tout cas
et c'est le volonté de maintenir le cap
c'est à dire que ceci qui est embêtant
c'est que on ne connaît pas les
objectifs on ne connaît pas les mesures
et on n'arrête pas de changer de
position et dans donc on ne sait rien
finalement on fait une réforme pour dire
qu'on a fait une réforme est la seule
chose qui reste c'est une petite chose
qui est de transformer un système à un
autre système à points
donc le système à points dont on n'a pas
encore bien vu qu'elle était l'incidence
est elle et ce ne sont pas des
simulations qui n'existe pas qui
pourrait nous dire donc on est on est
vraiment dans une réforme d'amateurs et
c'est encore une fois l'amateurisme qui
prime
alors comme d'autoritarisme extrême
rappellera à chaque fois parce que c'est
la france est ridiculisée dans le monde
entier c'est la réf c'est là la
répression qu'ont subis les jaunes tout
le monde a quand même plus de douze
mille arrestations en 3000 condamnation
mille gilet jaune envoyé en prison des
centaines de blessés graves
oui c'est plus que de l'amateur y as été
absolument pas nécessaire ici parce que
c'est
amateurs qui ne font ça de cette façon
si jamais ces approches mentionnait
qu'il ne ferait pas de cette façon que
l'on reçoit il ya des manifestations aux
flambeaux ils ont été bien embêté les
policiers mis leur neveu n'a pas fait de
demande à ces personnes
c'est le passé tranquillement il ya
aucun incident en une incidence nulle
part en france
et ben voilà lui quand il provoque une
manifestation vendredi qu'il s'est très
bien déroulé calmement et dans la bonne
humeur moi que c'est pas les policiers
n'ont ni les policiers vont pouvoir des
idéaux dans la police mais c'est quoi
les oreilles c'est parce que j'ai des
mains sur la balance je n'ai pas dit ça
ne bouge pas on met la culpabilité sur
les policiers alors qu'il ya des gens
qui donnent des ordres
le conseil d'état a retoqué a demandé au
gouvernement de revoir sa copie en tout
cas sur cette réforme des retraites
il a soulevé de nombreuses questions en
tout cas patrick mennucci le conseil
d'état c'est un camouflet pour le
gouvernement alors que le texte vient de
passer devant le conseil des ministres
c'est totalement inédit dans la 7ème
république que le conseil d'état voit
les raisons et qui est en général
d'ailleurs une institution qu'il faut
qu'on connaît mal mais qui a toujours
fait évoluer le droit administratif dans
le bon sens l'appui de l'état voilà mais
qui prend toujours des positions qui
sont en position extrêmement rigoureuse
à l'égard de la république d'akossi fils
au fond la question qui était posée par
le gouvernement c est ce que cette
réforme dans le conseil d'état ne juge
pas l'opportunité de la réforme 2010 son
avis est ce que cette réforme
contiennent des risques juridiques ou
des risques constitutionnels
une fois que le wallon s'est
effectivement que c'est d'état dit
premièrement nous on n'a pas eu le temps
de travailler vous me l'avez donné le
texte le 3 janvier vous avez changé
entre temps
je crois que c'est l'état d'ici faut
dire si l'occasion leur donne des
modifications etc et dont le conseil
d'état dit au gouvernement que il n'est
pas en capacité aujourd'hui de dire si
le texte est sera constitutionnel ou
pourrait être amené à stocker par le
conseil au ciel donc on trouve
ce que dit loïc évidemment qui est
l'amateurisme que je parle de pataugeage
on est on est dans les mêmes choses et
aux fossettes cet avis qui est examinée
très sérieuse même pas par le conseil
d'état aux fourneaux conseil d'état dit
qu'il ya plusieurs problèmes
la question du financement ce n'est pas
financé mais ça ça y est d'une
perfection ce que d'en faire lacunaire
du oui non mais bien sûr puisqu'on a
tout renvoyé à une espèce de de
confiance voilà une conférence avec le
medef les syndicats etc
alors qu'à la réforme à l'origine il
devait régler les problèmes de
financement exactement ce qu'il faut le
rappeler quand exactement
et donc causer les a dit c'est pas
financer ben oui pour le moins puisque
nous savons qu'il ya une une conférence
apprirent conseil d'état dit aussi que
ordonnance rien alors les 29 ordonnance
c'est très intéressant parce que moi
j'ai été moi-même rapporteurs des textes
d'habilitation ordonnance assemblée
nationale donc c'est un travail sérieux
un travail de commission des lois il ya
ya ya énormément de va-et-vient que vous
faites ça 29 fois vous allez vous
soumettre 29 fois parce que puisque
c'est une ambulance c'est automatique
à l'avis du conseil constitutionnel
c'est à dire que 29 fois vous allez
avoir des gens qui vont saisir le
conseil constitutionnel et qui vont
examiner votre loi d'habilitation et
donc votre ordonnance avant l'audience
c'est à dire la loi d'habilitation 206
la loi d'habilitation
elle peut être mise et que les
ordonnances puisse être promulguée le
vous rendez compte que 29 fois dans une
situation va se mettre le gouvernement
sous une couette et donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'alors que président
république prémunissent disent que tout
ça va se régler en juillet
on suppose à la fin de la session
parlementaire moi je vous parie que
cette affaire-là n'est pas terminée à la
fin de l'année 2011 et on verra en tout
cas des engagements voit disparaître du
texte est ce que soulève aussi le
conseil d'état les promesses de
revalorisation des salaires notamment si
les enseignants
il ne pourrait finalement plus être dans
le texte au final loïk le floch prigent
avec votre regard d'ancien patron qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette réforme des
retraites c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas
quels sont les objectifs c'est que quand
dans une entreprise on dit voilà ce
qu'on a envie de faire et puis à l'heure
où près on explique la manière d'y
arriver
moi je n'ai toujours pas compris au bout
de toute cette période il est à de gens
qui sont exprimés j'ai toujours pas
compris ce qu'on voulait et en
particulier en ce qui concerne le chef
d'entreprise que je suis et que j'ai été
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir si à
un moment on va encore augmenter les
cotisations qu'on me demande c'est à
dire qu'on va augmenter encore la
pression des vikes la pression alors
qu'aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
compétitions internationales mais
charges sont déjà trop important aux
effets que c'est ce qu'on va recommencer
encore une fois après avoir dit
l'inversé il ya un phénomène à leur goût
parce que moi quand j'entends mais on va
organiser un débat avec les partenaires
sociaux
moi j'entends les syndicats vont venir
voir les patrons disant il faut
augmenter la dose et et moi je peux plus
dire que je considère que si jamais on
augmente encore les charges sociales
dans l'industrie française
nous perdons la compétitivité de notre
devise qui est déjà précaire qui est
déjà très précaire
à la suite de ce qui est fait sur
l'électricité où c'était le seul endroit
on était compétitif et on a pris 25%
depuis deux ans à cause donc in her déjà
abrité difficile mais alors si
maintenant dans cette combine à cause
des radiations et système reste à voir à
cause a paru beaucoup de choses à cause
du fait qu'on a voulu faire une
compétition entre les gens qui allaient
servir l'électricité qui était
complètement artificiel puisqu'il ya un
producteur tout garner est quand même là
fait on fait des bêtises
renoir sur la conférence que tu dis les
syndicats vont aller voir le patronat
pour dire il faut payer plus ça va plus
ça va ça va au pacte et oui mais ce qui
va je voudrais te rassure et moi ça me
rassure pas moi mais ça peut rassurer le
patronat c'est que
le gouverneur a remis un clic et c'est à
dire que si les choses ne lui paraissent
pas convenable il le fera lui-même
et comme il a plutôt la baie l'habitude
d'être du côté du medef que du côté de
des syndicats a mon avis tu as donc pas
beaucoup de risques de risque une
nouvelle motion qu'ils sont sûrs en tout
cas été va être portée par la france 1
soumise au gouvernement une motion de
censure contre le gouvernement qui avait
déjà été portée le 14 janvier dernier
son succès puisque l'opposition n'avait
pas suivi ce que ça a des chances
d'aboutir cette fois selon vous georges
kuzmanovic une motion de censure
pourrait mettre en péril cette réforme
des retraites ou pas non ce qui met en
péril non pas de ça ça fonctionne pas
une fois qu'une majorité de députés
qu'ils avaient tort ils ont une majorité
la réplique aux marches et ses alliés ou
une majorité de députés
par contre c'est nécessaire à faire pour
manifester dans le cadre de l'hémicycle
à l'assemblée nationale je pense que ça
sera soutenue comme ça a été pour la
défense d'un homme par d'autre part les
députés y compris de là les républicains
ou des socialistes parce que il ya tout
un tas de gens qui seront posées à cette
date députés qui sont opposés à cette à
cette réforme
mais ce qui importe c'est du théâtre
georges wilson suite à donner
si je sais bien forcément hâte et ac/dc
cher ce ne serait pas forcément il a été
blessé du théâtre mais on est d'accord
mais ce qui porte un coup fatal au à ce
gouvernement
et s'ils s'entêtent on ne sait pas ou
peu les pays c'est que après 50 jours de
grève et alors que on nous parle que les
tout le monde souffre évidemment c'est
difficile à négocier des grèves de
soufre des grèves des 61% de la
population aux fissures les chiffres
officiels soutient ce mouvement de grève
c est opposée à cette réforme après 50
jours
plus maintenant un deuxième paquet si
l'espace actuel devrait la retirer oui
mais cette attaque est numéro un
deuxième c'est le conseiller d'état
conseiller d'état tu l'as dit excédé
gens que rien n'assure pas d'un courage
non plus excessifs
ben là carrément à 10 baisser ils disent
c'est n'importe quoi en accumulation de
plus il faut traduire le qui explique
très très clairs ils disent mais c'est
n'importe quoi ce que vous proposez
c'est pas chiffré on sait pas quelles
vont être les effets on sait pas combien
ça va coûter
ça n'a aucun sens c'est passé tout a été
dit clairement on perd
du temps en discuter al'aube george sand
et santé renom
vous avez dit je suis pas d'accord avec
vous sur le côté amateur
leur problème c'est que ce qu'il
souhaite
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
macron lors de son discours du mur à ces
cas c'est ce qui a été fait après le
conseil national de la résistance
c'est faire un système par
capitalisation or il ne peut pas venir
même après tant d'années d'inféodation
aux thèses néolibérales devenu de
maastricht de bruxelles
ils ne peuvent pas venir à la télévision
il ya vous savez quoi
hop on va tout casser vous allez perdre
un tiers de votre retraite
et puis ça va être par capitalisation
comme aux états unis et puis inch allah
on verra bien si ça fonctionne avec si
les marchés vous ne perdez pas votre
écoute sur la réalité on peut on peut
donc le dernier soutient qu'un
gouvernement c'est celui blackrock
oui on peut avoir cette volonté là moi
que je tiens bon d'accord avec trois
missions mais ça passera pas et donc je
suis un terminal de gamme et de la liste
de la mettre en oeuvre dans une espèce
de de foire d'empoigné
moi j'appelle ça de jeu quotidien qu'il
n'y a pas d'homme politique ce que ça ne
peut pas être aidé à rassurer mais il
n'y a pas de dogme politique les seuls
hommes politiques ya ils sont cachés au
ministère des affaires étrangères les
choses comme ça et puis pour le reste on
n'a que des rigolos
c'est ma vérité c est mal fait ça est
fait pour toi même si à poursuivre la
part l'objectif que tu décris non mais
même s'ils poursuivent l'objectif est il
écrit dans mall flagrante ne leur dit
pas merci aujourd'hui un alors 61 des
patrons devraient retirer cette réforme
des retraites 61% des français voyez
l'explication de cib et n'diaye qui nous
à quelqu'un d'aller écouter on les sauve
et d'exaspération d'abord pendant par le
énormément qu'il y ait beaucoup de
manifestations qui est parfois de la
violence je pense que ça traduit de la
lassitude et que les français ont envie
de passer à autre chose
il ya trop
ça c'est un gouvernement qui sait plus
où il est né il dit toujours la même
chose les gens n'ont pas cours
d'arguments non mais les gens n'ont pas
compris c'est le légère n'ont pas
compris les syndicats n'ont pas compris
les citoyens n'ont pas mis ce qui brille
ce que manifeste du manifeste d'un pack
aubry les commentateurs les
éditorialistes donc pas comme bree est
meilleure le conseil d'état pas compris
de hier que qu'ils comprennent
c'est ça la logique de ce que dit madame
ndèye c'est tout c'est parce qu'ils ont
compris
mais à 10 contre 10 patrick c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire parce qu ils ont
compris
mais ils ont compris des choses
différentes et extraordinaire rappelle
toi que madame ndiaye
elle a dit des énormités sur la réforme
et même sur les retraites il ya deux
jours c'est pour ça que je te dis qu'ils
ont compris d'échouer différence alors
c'est alors ça c'est peut-être un
concept de en même temps un peu
surprenant mais moi c'est ça que je vous
chargerez qu'on écoute maintenant
emmanuel macron ce qu'il a dit on a
expliqué et quand on explique on
comprend normalement écouter cette étape
au la semaine dernière qu'il faut
demander ça c'est me lisent d'abord
peut-être parce que collectivement on ne
porte passer le micro la caméra sur les
explications calme et apaisée 2 qu'est
ce que c'est aujourd'hui et où on va ce
qui est important si vous voulez les
français comprennent ils font comment
alors expliquer qu'il faut que chacun
explique pose des questions on explique
qu est-ce que ces systèmes aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est le système de demain
et comment on y passe comme on est en
train de le faire l'art calmement
quand on expliquer qu on écoute et on
arrive à comprendre quand on quand on
écoute généralement on arrive à
comprendre un petit peu qu on est
cependant encore sous jospin ce que
chirac ce sarkozy ou hollande sous mac
row quand le peuple n'est pas d'accord
et que le pape a parfaitement compris et
pareillement pour le tc en 2000 quand le
traité constitutionnel européen en 2005
ça manque de pédagogie l'eau chaque fois
ça va aller se faire du je trouve que si
j'arrivais feuilleton paraît tout ça là
on est arrivé à un niveau
y'a rien à voir avec tout ce que tu
racontes rien à voir il le traité
constitutionnel européen
on répétait vous n'avez pas compris il
faut bien des bougies alors vous avez
fait le pack budgétaire aurais tu n'a
voulu parler il y tue n'avait pas alors
je vais dire toujours un rêve tu n'avais
pas mes seuls choisi lui - de gilet
jaune vert et non mais l'argument j'ai
été utilisé utilise arguments non
mesdames que moi j'étais sa chose
c'est la seule chose qui soit vrai ce
que les médias c'est gras de
suffisamment de pédagogie ils ont ils
ont essayé d'expliquer quelque chose
d'inexplicable alors bon mais c'est
compliqué on peut pas leur en vouloir et
un texte extrêmement extrêmement
compliqué c'est à dire change en parler
d'un régime où il y a des soucis
incapable de vous dire quel est le texte
final est ce qu'ils aillent dans votre
conseil sens mais les blues un régime
universel c'est désormais le problème de
colomiers vient y viennent du début
c'est à dire que comme vous décidez de
faire le régime par points
admettons et que vous le larder des
régimes spéciaux de côté et de l'âge de
la retraite de l'autre vous êtes obligé
de rentrer dans ce type de processus les
régimes spéciaux
tout le monde le sait d'ailleurs c'est
quasiment réglé savate réglé oui cette
ligne en a d'autres voilà j'ai d'autres
mais aussi qu'il faut trente ans pour
liquider les régimes spéciaux mais on
dit aux gens voilà ce qui
viennent d'être embauchées ceux qui sont
logés n'y sommes plus droit et puis les
autres ça finit en ciseaux c'est comme
ça qu'on fait pour des régimes spéciaux
mais là ils ont non seulement pas fait
ça ils ont tous mis ensemble ils ont
tous revu de façon à être certain que la
ratp la sncf etc soient bien dans le
mouvement et après ils ont sorti leur
histoire de sous 24 ans de kiala
interroge claude et puis le pire c'est
que tous les citoyens se demandent est
ce qu'il gagne est ce qu'ils perdent
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour eux
parce que la retraite c'est pas juste
une fin de mois
c'est une très noble dans la vie voilà
on va alors soit 7,2 soit trois ans on
arrête et les jeunes espèrent c'est une
espérance
comme tous les français tous les humains
je suppose qu'ils vivent dans des pays
où les retraites existe malheureusement
et on n'est pas la majorité
et ils se disent voilà donc je vais dans
ma vie je vais être plus tranquille je
vais m'occuper de mes petites choses que
j'ai compris qu'il y avait compris qu'il
savait s'il y avait quelques points
claire un des points claire c'était
qu'on va passer pour ce qu'ils ont dans
le près de 25 ans important les français
sont proches du pid donc ils savent que
si on compte les 25 meilleures années
enfin pas les 25 meilleures années mais
les 43 meilleur c'est que vu que chacun
commence la vie commence eh ben ils sont
diverses et pas c'est pas compliqué ça
vachement hyper multiplication mairie
mais c'est qu'on en est là le conseil
d'état dit un point 1 euro cotisé n'est
même pas équivalents un point sépare
alors c'est ce qu'on nous a répété
depuis le début et ce n'est pas possible
je pense qu'en plus il ya point
fondamental qui était d'essayer dire le
système va est universel qui a été
compris comme un système uniforme et que
jamais c'est à dire que le problème a
été mal posé depuis le départ depuis le
débat est la véritable le véritable
problème c'était pas celui-là c'était
sus de la politique industrielle
j'espère qu'on va y revenir c'est à dire
que si jamais on a une industrie
française qui a qui est passé de 20 6%
ou 24 % à 11 % du pib
ça a conduit à une situation difficile
pour faire la retraite
répartition et si jamais on ne regroupe
le pôle industrie française on est
incapable de passer sur les retraites
c'est ça le vrai sujet alors ce sujet
n'a pas été traitées et ont dit bon ya
pénurie alors il ya pénurie guette
poutine devait donc on va essayer de
régler la pénurie c'est le premier mal
posé le problème le problème fondamental
c'est celui-là politique à l'échelle de
la france et celui là n'a jamais été
pris en compte au nom de l'emploi et
donc de l'emploi et de l'emploi
et d'ailleurs c'est incompréhensible que
d'aller ce type de débat on ne parle pas
d'eux des nouveaux métiers de l'ubs et
risation comment il faut les jeunes qui
travaillent chez hubert qui portent des
ddd repas comme en forme tous les
anneaux ou supprimé les matches c'est ça
la question
la question est là et 4 minimum pour à
1000 euros pour tout le monde pour les
faits non c'est pas vrai parce que ça
existe déjà mais s'appelle le minimum
vieillesse il était à 890 euros
et aussi pourquoi les gens c'est par
exemple pourquoi les paysans ne prennent
pas le minimum vieillesse parce que
c'est pas une retraite c'est une
prestation sociale et comme peu après
leur décès aller chercher leur leurs
héritiers pour récupérer l'argent parce
qu'ils avaient un bien d'une valeur ça
peut arriver pour des paysannes de
300000 euros 200 mille euros voire plus
si vous avez beaucoup de terre et voilà
pourquoi ils l'utilisent pas quand on
entend les paysannes diriger une petite
trappe
c'est essentiellement pour ses
questionne tout ça existe restez avec
nous on continue ce débat sur la grogne
sociale alors qu'est ce qu'on s'est
manifesté dans la rue emmanuel macron a
reçu les patrons du monde entier cette
semaine à versailles on en parle dans
quelques minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un prix donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fonio et sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
des sacs transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
la france a été la destination
principale des peintres russes dans la
seconde moitié du xviie siècle
[Musique]
on
rapine et pour les noces c'est ainsi
qu'on les connaît pas par leur nom mais
on les connaît par les tableaux qu'ils
ont fait nous vivions un peu de sous et
très joyeusement mais nous y travaillons
aussi très sérieusement écrit bogoliubov
nichols et unique but mais en même temps
la lumière est très proche de celle de
la russie
chez nous la rivière c'est la volga ici
c'est la mer jean tu es si belle et
romantique
le vent est aussi intense et puissant
[Musique]
et
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique écoutez c'est une république qui
se préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs georges fritsch patrick
mennucci est notre invité loïk le floch
prigent ancien dirigeant ancien
directeur pardon de cabinet du ministre
de l'industrie et anciens grands
dirigeants d'entreprises publiques
auteur également je le rappelle de il ne
faut pas se tromper aux éditions et dit
elle après avoir défendu son bilan
économique à dunkerque lundi emmanuel
macron a réuni le lendemain elle les
patrons des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire pour la première fois à
l'elysée puis réception en grande pompe
à versailles pour la troisième édition
deux choses france
le président qui s'est réjoui des
investissements promis par les
entreprises étrangères et il a regretté
cette semaine d'être toujours présenté
comme le président des riches
moi je veux bien tous les jours me faire
appeler président des riches
je ne le suis pas et je ne suis pas
défenseur de qui que ce soit de quelques
catégories
je suis défenseur de l'intérêt de la
nation dans l'intérêt général et d'une
ambition que je veux pour notre pays il
faut que tout le monde explique à quoi
ça sert quand tomber quand on fait ce
qu'on a fait sur dix est c'est fait la
flat tax et là je besoin de vous
collectivement bah ça sert à permettre
de réinvestir dans notre pays et notre
économie est en quelque sorte dans nos
pays il ya beaucoup de gens pour
défendre le nationalisme productif et
dire il faut produire en france
mais les mêmes bien souvent disent on
n'aime pas les riches et on n'aime pas
les gens qui gagnent de l'argent en
france un capitalisme sans capital ça
existe pas un gars vitalisme sans
capital ça n'existe pas qu'est ce que
vous voudrez vous réagissez à 1
seulement je suis d'accord avec ce qu'il
a dit là sur le cabinet son capital mais
je l'écris souvent donc si jamais
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
difficulté où nous sommes en france
c'est qu'effectivement l'argent a été
drainé par l'immobilier et pas par
l'industrie et le fait qu' ils
réunissent des proches des patrons
industriels qu'il soit petit ou grand
cette symbolique me plaît derrière il ya
une autre symbolique
oui d'ailleurs et ça fonctionne on est
sur l'attractivité de la france est
plutôt bonne alors la deuxième le
deuxième élément d une hausse symbolique
presse à brix et je réunis les patrons
des nti nom il choisit il son
administration ont choisi quelques
patrons deux pays
estimé que tout ça c'est de l'étatisme
c'est stupide de tei se débrouille tout
seul
si jamais on leur donne une bonne raison
que la taille intermédiaire si jamais si
jamais on leur fait une politique une
bonne politique économique
si jamais elles sont pas embêtés par les
administrations à tout moment eh bien
elles font la bonne industrie c'est bon
donc c'est pas la peine d'en choisir
quelques-uns et l'or et de leur dire
voilà vous êtes sélectionné vous êtes
des meilleurs je vois pas en quoi l'état
peut dire celui-là il est bon celui-là
il est mauvais dit tu as deux autres
sympathiques l'autre l'autre symbolique
qui était qui est embêtant c'est de dire
à côté de ça je rampe je regarde
l'ensemble des patrons alors non plus de
l'industrie mais les patrons des
entreprises alors fait que c'est
différent à dire que lorsqu'on prend en
outre l'ours quatre ans lorsqu'on vend
des bons ce qui est écrit
lorsqu'on prend des banquiers comme
jpmorgan morgan staley on prend pas des
entreprises on prend un grand banquier
qui va même chose donc on confond le
monde industriel devant des entreprises
on prend des gens qui sont complètement
mondialisée or le message qu'il fallait
passer dans un premier temps était j'ai
envie de faire une politique
industrielle française et dans un
deuxième temps on dit je vais réunir les
patrons mondiaux qui investissent en
france s ils font l'investissement en
france
eh bien la france est vendu à la découpe
qu'elle a vendu garde investissement
quand même en france oui alors c'est une
bonne nouvelle c'est une petite nouvelle
grossièrement ce qu'il faut en france et
de leur de son milliard pour retrouver
une industrie française possédées par
des français aujourd'hui cette industrie
n'est pas possédé par des français et
est vendue à la découpe
on voit bien c'est à dire les nouvelles
des cinq dernières années
c'était une nouvelle on a vendu à sa
nombre de grandes entreprises et en
arrondi également des andes dut y est on
a vendu de plaisir d'entreprise on a un
problème général de financement est ce
qu'on fout demandez à l'extérieur tenue
financer alors que nous avons une d
épargne les plus importantes mondiales
donc il faut essayer de revenir à la
raison et qu'on dirait que la
souveraineté patriotisme d'entreprise et
patrice peut tout court est absolument
indispensable si on veut sauver notre
pays et le fait de montrer ses patrons
internationaux en disant oh la la c'est
merveilleux vous allez créer 300 emplois
à dunkerque où des terrains je pense que
ces preneurs
est-ce que c'est l'emploi voilà
justement c'est ce qu'attend est-ce que
ça va créer des emplois concrètes
alors alors je vous donne un exemple
c'est à dire que lorsque vous allez sur
les chantiers de l'atlantique petit à
vous avez des ouvriers français sont en
minorité d'or de 10% lors de 10% posit à
2 vous êtes en train de dire c'est se
choisit de l'atlantique on va le vendre
italien et puis vous réjouissez en
grande fanfare du fait que vous allez
avoir une commande de 2 milliards
aujourd'hui de l'atlantique
tout ça c'est un c'est un mensonge bon
c'est la branche j'ai un peu un certain
j'ai travaillé ou polonais aux estoniens
et roumains c'est bon c'est bon pour la
france c'est ça que vous voulez dire
c'est ça qui se passe donc il faut il
faut aller aller sur les chantiers
l'atlantique plutôt que de parler à
versailles à l'antique et vous verrez ce
qui se passe au rouge de l'atlantique
bon c'était pas ça pour tous les
travailleurs français sur les chances
que s'il n'y a pas de travailleurs
français sur la jetée agentique d'une
part parce que la formation n'a pas été
fait à cause de delà de l'apprentissage
qui n'a pas été fait il ya plus de
soudeur français il ya plus chaudes
renier il ya plus à tout un ensemble
d'éléments qui n'existent pas petits tas
et deux parce que finalement c'est moins
cher que de prendre un polonais un
estonien que prendra français donc on
est dans les contradictions du système
et tant qu'on ne règle pas les
contradictions du système industriel
aujourd'hui en france on est dans
l'embarras alors que cette contradiction
ce je pense que pour moi c'était
incroyable de voir les gens se
réjouissent de commandes de 2 milliards
ou jamais a tenté de lui mais celle là
ne sont pas son or seuls mais on connaît
passionnant ils exigent journalistes et
hommes politiques exilés cabinet ihs les
idées si jamais les fonctionnaires ils
sont chargés de sélectionner 120 pays
pour les mettre à versailles et pour le
rendre leur dire vous êtes les meilleurs
du monde mais ils sont pas capables
d'aller sur le terrain voir ce qui se
passe sur le théâtre antique
alors j'ai toujours pas capable de
savoir pression identique sont en vente
actuellement et qu'on va les vendre aux
italiens qui vont supprimer un grand
ensemble des fabrications fait là
j'aurais qu'on ne sait plus on va perdre
le marché de thales sur les écoutes et
les éléments je propose un peu le truc
et eric coquerel à présent qui lui était
à versailles mais côté manifestants
quand il ya eu ce rassemblement des
patrons parce qu'il estime que ce
n'était pas le moment alors que les
français sont dans la rue d'organiser ce
type d'événement écoutez monsieur macro
j'allais dire fait une provocation de
plus c'est à dire venir en pleine
mobilisation sociale d'une ampleur
historique avec les 200 plus grands
patrons se pavaner dans un lieu qui est
quand même symbolique d'un régime qui
est pas celui de la république terre à
versailles
bon je trouve ça je crois que c'est
parce qu'ils se rendent compte à quel
point c'est ça une image assez
insupportable au reste du pays voilà il
est avec ce dont il fait profiter de ses
largesses et de sa politique depuis deux
ans une bio au détriment de du pays à
force de casser ce qui reste de l'état
social à force de faire des cadeaux
fiscaux aux plus riches
voilà vous y réagir très courts et de
politique
oui petit politique donc je crois que là
il faut arrêter ces bêtises
ce n'est pas ça le problème de fond
posées par cette serre en devient
néanmoins un fossé on ressent bien entre
les bons résultats en tout cas dont se
félicite emmanuel macron et ce que
ressentent les français dans la rue
aujourd'hui qui continue de se mobiliser
pour leur pouvoir d'achat
georges kiejman au beach le saut faussé
est réel ou est-ce que c'est du ressenti
un fossé très réel ce sont les études je
le rappelle ici régulièrement faites par
l' ocde très régulièrement sur l'état
réel du chômage en europe et donc en
france qui est l'ordre de 20%
puisqu'il ne comptabilise pas de la
manière dont tu es compatibilité
actuelle rares d'achat augmenter mais on
les détourne les aléas en france a
dépassé les moyennes ou si c'est
concrètement les gens ne ressens pas de
quelle manière sont calculés ces
moyennes mais l' ocde qui n'est pas une
organisation particulièrement socialiste
match épique
arrivé à ce chiffre de 20 % 5 1 français
sur 5 qui en âge de travailler ne peut
pas vivre de son travail et messieurs le
floch prigent on l'a très bien dit un
des grands problèmes et ça c'est la
politique menée par l'union européenne
ce sont les travailleurs détachés
c'est cette disposition là qui permet à
toute une armée de gens de venir
travailler en france pour moins cher et
qui cassent les possibilités de
développement d'une compétence de
relancer des écoles où on pourrait
apprendre ces métiers qui se perdent en
france et en seront ceux on se lie les
mains et donc je suis quasiment d'accord
tout ce qu'a dit loïc nous avons nous
avions une vingtaine de personnes signé
une tribune en début juillet dans
marianne contre le projet poséidon en
expliquant qu'elle espère c'est la vente
de naval groupe à fincantieri ces
italiens dans une logique généralisée
depuis des années de ventes delà de la
france allant quand on se félicite
d'avoir des investissements mais c'est
pas des investissements ça ne cesser
brader notre capacité industrielle et
donc notre futur parce que quand on vend
c'est ces entreprises qui sont souvent
sont très hautes technologies c'est en
ce couple aimant parce que si on a déjà
plus les métiers de l'industrie de base
parce qu'ils sont partis ailleurs que
moyenne ça devient difficile en europe
il sait bien c'est mais c'est dans ces
industries là qu'on aurait les moyens de
rebondir de rebondir à l'avenir et on se
les coupes et c'est encore la preuve
qu'il n'ya absolument aucune politique
industrielle au sommet de l'état depuis
très longtemps et monsieur macro
s'illustre parfaitement c'est un vrai
problème
allah seul petit point on peut être je
serais pas d'accord c'est que papa part
pas d'accord mais c'est qu'il ya un
changement structurel
tu vas être exprimées ici mais on est
passé d'un capitalisme industriel et
nationales ou des gens avaient des
usines et puis on avait un accord avec
les syndicats en améliorer les salaires
on s'organise et on vivait ensemble on
avait un destin commun à un capitalisme
qui tendanciellement devient financier
international cette année on a eu la
télé car quand je parle de capitalisme
mois industriel jeu printemps 2010
industrie voilà ce serait bien de ne pas
encaisser alger ici parce que quelqu'un
rentre par exemple je souhaite à café de
riz semestrielles voilà avec la flat tax
avec
lisf ce qu'on s'est retrouvé comme cette
année avec un record absolu
encore une fois battu à une des
richesses des derniers des dividendes du
cac 40 et 60 milliards bon bah les
records de 2007 donc avant une autre
crise qui est un peu inquiétant il faut
savoir que 50 % de ceux de ce qu'il
était les capitaux du cac 40 ne sont pas
français donc c'est pas très intéressant
c'est et il se retrouve effectivement
malheureusement président des riches
alors qu'il devrait être président d'un
renouveau industriel en france est sûre
elle sera identique et puis ça prend
pour lui samedi dans l'est stupide de
dire des riches des rides
il est il est plus attiré par les
banquiers que pour les industriels et ce
billet sur les tables d'accord c'est
qu'ils soient plus attirés par les
abriel que les banquiers oui parce que
la solution selon vous pour redresser
économiquement ce pays c'est les
industries et non pas les banques
absolument vraiment c'est clair c'est
clair et on est quand on pense aux
banquiers moi je pense toujours à des
banquiers d'affaires qui aujourd'hui or
pour faire des transactions entre
industriels se sucrent avec des agios
extraordinaire alors qu'ils sont
inutiles moi j'ai fait toutes mes
réquisitions avant de passer sans se
sont à avoir deux banquiers qui
conseillent alors donc aujourd'hui on a
inventé le fait qu'il faut un banquier
conseil
si jamais on est incapable de faire à un
accord entre industriels sont banque et
de son banquier vous savez qu'ils sont
les banquiers de fiat chrysler peugeot
ouais moi c'est alors mots mais je pense
que c'était quelque chose qui me paraît
très bien pu être fait sans manquer
mails et mes chronos qui en a marre
qu'on le traite de président des riches
patrick mennucci c'est une étiquette qui
va lui coller quoi qu'il fasse
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est une
étiquette qui veut qu'il va lui coule et
là on est après deux ans et demi de
pouvoir y aller là bas a dit on a eu les
gilet jaune qui était quand même pas
terminé mais avec un avertissement game
mais ils ont obtenu un pouvoir d'achat
c'est gilles et jo j'ai juste les
chiffres qui sont parus 853 euros
supplémentaires en moyenne bien
évidemment avec une une répartition qui
est très inégale donc qu'il n'est pas
forcément le cas pour tous les ménages
mais en tout cas le pouvoir d'achat a
bien augmenté en moyenne de 25 et demi
poursuit mais le râleur
l'an dernier la question la question
n'est pas toujours financière il ya bien
sûr une part de nécessité d'acheter 2
pour nash a augmenté mais il ya aussi
une part immatériel dans la façon de
diriger un pays
et je pense que le président la
république met toute son énergie pour se
faire détester par 75% des français pour
des réseaux extrêmement diverses et pas
pour des raisons tout à fait factuel et
puis d'autres parce que il le voit
parler comme on vient de le voir parler
espèce de monde ce que dit coquerel je
suis d'accord avec loic ce aucun sens
que l'on questionne la république fasse
des choses avec les entreprises
étrangères
il a bien raison il habite il il a bien
raison
la vraie question c'est pas de faire des
choses et les entreprises c'est à quoi
ça sert ce qui fait c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on est là pour aller chercher de
l'industrie ou est ce que c'est la
description que fait logique de ce qui
se passe je crois que c'est lui qui
réseau donc c'est ça et après on a on a
une question je crois qui est autour de
deux lits sf fait des premières mesures
qu'il a pris on a beau dire que oui
c'est pas grave moi je crois que c'est
symboliquement est réellement très grave
parce que quand vous supprimer l'impôt
sur la fortune qui avait une valeur
d'abord de rentabilité économique pour
le pays mais qui avaient aussi france
les milliardaires ne se ne se sont
jamais aussi bien portés ont été plus
vite que dans nos vies
mais je continue à prendre pendant qu'il
n'y a pas je continue à penser qu'il
n'ya pas que les calculs financiers
il y à aussi il y a aussi selon
ressentent les gens les gens ont
ressenti qu ils ont recettes dit que ben
ils gagnent ce qu'ils gagnent ils
travaillent et puis il ya des gens qui à
petit payer un impôt et qui sur toutes
les parties financières de cet impôt ne
paye plus parce que ils se sont enrichis
d'ailleurs sénat mais parce que le
problème de la suppression de l'isf
c'est que on n'a pas supprimé dans
l'impôt sur la fortune
toute la partie immobilière noguier un
certain nombre de vieilles personnes au
ralenti etc
et s'ils considéraient qu'ils n'ont pas
été touchés par la suppression et puis
de l'autre côté la flat tax
témoin j'ai des copains qui ont pas j'ai
pas les copains que tu as loïc mois
qu'il ya des entreprises est immense
mais j'ai coupé qui ont des petites
entreprises amorcée mais mon à marseille
et qui me disent mais c'est
extraordinaire parce que je payais 33
maintenant je paye 30 d'année prochaine
je vais payer 28 des impôts sur les
sociétés et il y à une satisfaction et
en génie mais vous êtes tata augmente et
et essar et tata fille le prix mais
voilà je veux répondre je veux répond à
ce que les patrick en deux mots c'est à
dire que si jamais ils avaient plutôt
que de dire c'est de l'amateurisme
encore plus tôt de dire je supprime qui
est sa fille l'avait dit tout argent il
réinvestit très investi dans l'industrie
sera des taxes et quels qu'ils soient et
avoue ne s'était absolument
cet épisode est différent voilà mais je
dis est ce que c'est
c'est là le c2 puisqu'on est dans la
symbolique certes elle devance je pense
que le fait de dire je veux tout ce qui
est va dans l'industrie c'est bon mais
tout ce qui va dans l'immobilier sam de
france ça ne fait pas de l'emploi je
pense que ça cesse étaient audibles est
ce que les usa en gardant en gardant le
bouillet savoure c'est en faisant le
jury est ce que tu attends dans sa
phrase quand il dit j'ai supprimer l isf
la flat tax saha et et quelques dit-il à
ce moment là exactement le contraire de
ce que tu dis il dit l'argent n'a été
réinvesti dans l'économie française
c'est ce qu'on vient de l'ensemble c'est
un mensonge éhonté
ce qui n'est pas le sortir et c'est donc
ce sujet
les prix y est et qui était à traiter
mais c'est vrai c'est pour ça que à
chaque fois qu'on fait une réforme et je
reprends la retraite et je reprends tout
notre conversation il faudrait objectifs
quels objectifs
mais si l'objectif c'est de faire
d'industrie ont réussi et si l'objectif
n'est pas de faire l'industrie on rate
et orlane radiés et il n'a pas compris
qu'il fallait arrêter france et en
construit capitalisme hors énorme
chercheuse manoli tu es juste pour
rappel que c'est lui qui s'est mis dans
cette situation d'une présence des
riches et il a l'impression qu'on lui a
collé l'étiquette mais quand il a fait
lien cff la taxe en même temps qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient en brad marsh est
labellisé chose à poyanne dingue
prenons deux essais de supprimer 900
postes en même temps là il prend à ce
que vraiment peu qu'ils soient qu'ils
sont comme ça là au bord de la cei de
pauvreté et on va leur prendre 5 euros
où ils seront ce qu'on s'accorde et j'en
sais on est or le problème c'est qu'en
france on a quand même le niveau de vie
vous que magali vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que il a donné en moyenne 850
euros mais en fait depuis 1910 et je
suis con à indexer les salaires sur les
prix
pardon sera l'inflation plus sur les
prix on a une à une chute plomb dans
leur sang
le ressenti n'est pas dans la capacité
de faire beaucoup de choses et on a bien
compris que ce ressenti voix elle
existait puisqu'au moment voilà qui
compense un peu d'argent supplémentaire
sur le litre d'essence ou de diesel la
france explose donc on voit bien à la
voit bien qu'on est con et un peu de
choses laissent aller s'en rend compte
et prendre effectivement la mesure de ce
qu'était la france n'est associé d'apax
ama a publié un rapport cette semaine
qui montre un petit peu les les
inégalités qui petit avoir justement
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres et la banque mondiale elle même
le dit la meilleure façon d'éradiquer
l'extrême pauvreté ce n'est pas la
croissance mais la réduction des
inégalités je vous laisse découvrir
c'est une projection pour café oxfam
justement pour montrer ce fossé entre
les plus riches et les plus pauvres
est ce que la banque mondiale a raison
il faut réduire d'abord les inégalités
et la politique actuelle évidemment vous
allez me le dire georges kiejman au vif
ce n'est pas sur celle évidemment que
oui c'est assez amusant de voir la
banque mondiale qui pendant des années
saborder temps bien que le pouvaient les
dispositions qui permet de répartir la
richesse dans
pays mais je sais pas mais chez makro on
est quand même dû du milieu de la banque
ce sont ceux-là rey se sont serrés
intérêts qui représentent réellement les
grands ce fait les grands financiers
transnationaux et lui qui aime tellement
les états unis plus que plutôt que de
pousser à une concentration maximum du
capital et des moyens vers très peu de
gens eh ben il faut aller vers plus de
coopération alors lui qui aime tellement
les les états unis il devrait dire s'il
ya un certain roberto wayne qui au
xviiie siècle proposer les états unis
déjà déjà disait que pioneer est à la
concentration plus on irait vers une
situation de crise et plus on partageait
mais on n'avait même plus on avait une
société stable et solide et qui va
ensemble quelque part elles ont parlé
d'un raid de la hausse du pouvoir
d'achat qui est réel sauf que ce n'est
pas durable est en fait les sales
inquiétudes des français c'est la
projection dans l'avenir et c'est là où
on revient en boucle et la retraite
c'est le steven en termes voilà qu'est
ce que je vais faire de ma vie impose
soit 203 arrêts et le moment où je
disparaîtrai est ce que je pourrais
avoir une vie agréable est ce que je
pourrais m'occuper de mes petits enfants
c'était et c'est un sentiment très
profond très fort qui explique ce qui
t'a bonne se passer on va passer au coup
de gueule à présent
[Musique]
je reviens vers vous patrick mennucci
c'est un coup de coeur pour la pièce de
théâtre l'opposition mitterrand versus
rocard de genre je me dis tout à fait
georges naudy au théâtre de l'atelier
depuis samedi dernier c'est la
construction de deux dialogues entre
françois mitterrand et michel rocard qui
n'a pas existé de sa passion c'était
michel rocard alors que je le dois qu'à
était évidemment sincérité de koné en
1981 et ils doivent décider
l'un et l'autre qui est candidat
président république en 1991 michel
rocard rend visite à françois mitterrand
rue de bièvre
ça ne s'est jamais passé comme ça mais
nous dire prendre des dialogues qu'ils
ont eu des choses qui se sont dites une
diction c'est une fiction mais c'est une
fiction formidable et qui je fais j'ai
trouvé c'est clair sur la politique est
claire total sur la politique et qui
monte pour la différence entre la
politique je dire de genre avec une
certaine profondeur
et puis ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui quoi
c'est pas exactement les d'amateurisme
là on a affaire à des personnalités
beaucoup plus profonde c'est michel
mayor se révèle très profond alors qu'on
a plutôt toujours là cet event que c'est
pas dur mitterrand qu'il était plus que
lui vous allez faire plaisir à jean paul
huchon la merci beaucoup et pour vous
georges kuzmanovic c'est un coup de
gueule la crainte on en parlait de
devoir encore un secteur stratégique de
la défense française affaiblie par des
investissements étrangers
et oui c'est l'entreprise massa a fait
écho au débat qu'on a eues aujourd'hui
c'est l'entreprise photonis qui est
leader mondial de la vision nocturne
alors ça devient monotone parce que
régulièrement je fais j'ai l'impression
que tous les répertorier pour les deux
semaines j'arrive avec ce genre de
nouvelles dernière c'était latécoère
donc mais c'est intéressant de noter ce
qu'on a une image un peu comme ca
négative en france ce sont les firmes
américaines qui sont positionnées les
films américaines que sont positionnés
comme pour latécoère comme pour d'autres
il ya des députés français qui disent se
serait pas une n'est pas une très bonne
idée pour notre notre industrie en
général pour notre positionnement
stratégique
la direction générale de l'armement qui
anime
un vrai souci en commission visiblement
rien n'est fait pour inciter à
sauvegarder sa dans le giron français
encore une fois c'est parce que ça fait
pas partie a pas de politique
industrielle de long terme
tout ça est abandonnée et juste une
dernière chose ce sont ce sont des
français des entreprises françaises qui
font des choses de grandes technologies
avoir un grand avancement ça marche en
fait parce qu'on a une idée comme ça là
qui est répandu en france on est nul
tout se passe à 6 comme valet ou chine
ou en russie
non en fait on peut faire et si on avait
au gouvernement des gens qui défendent
cette industrie on pourrait aller très
loin
une réaction à kigali maj l'image qu'on
donne c'est effectivement qu'on vient
faire le marché chez nous et donc c'est
l'image qui a été l'image de versailles
pour moi la symbolique versailles et on
se trouve que c'est vrai c'est à dire qu
on démantèle un certain nombre de
secteurs où prend les entreprises très
intéressant siens alors que alors que ça
fonctionne et qu'il suffirait de peu de
chose justement peut-être d'un soutien
bancaire à ces entreprises qui
apporterait des investisseurs n'ont pas
étranger mais français pour que nouri se
développe il y avait aucune raison que
latécoère parts comme ça euros aux états
unis aucune raison que photonics parts
et je connais un nombre d'entreprises
extrêmement élevés qui sont dans le même
état
dès qu'elles sont très technologique
qu'elles ont une importance capitale
pour notre avenir
eh bien il ya des prédateurs et ces
prédateurs sont encouragés par les
banquiers et c'est pour ça que je suis
con le gouvernement des banquiers merci
beaucoup merci patrick mennucci merci
georges kuzmanovic pour être
contribution merci beaucoup
loïk le floch prigent d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur arte france c'est la
fin de deux pôles it mag
restez avec nous l'info à suivre
[Musique]
la planète terre dans un futur proche
les mains de cash mais si un débris
spatial
audard f froid qui touche un satellite
d'un pays mange cela pourrait engendrer
un conflit autour de la terre l'espace
est polluée
il dérive en orbite d'innombrables
débris des millions de fragments de
tailles variées à cons